i want everyone to understand i'm not
slagging on baseball
when i say anybody from chicago even
with the last dance
even with the bulls doing what they did
it's a bears town
it's a football town the fact
that this if you need any if you need
any sort
of evidence it's the fact that the cubs
yesterday against the milwaukee brewers
alec mills
threw a no-hitter for the chicago cubs
and the
talk is of the bear's comeback win over
week one in detroit
that's a fact now i know i don't have
boots down there on the ground in
chicago
but these are facts cubs fans are nuts
i get it but the chicago bears
and mitchell trubisky put up 21
unanswered on the lions
yesterday and their head coach matt
maggie kind enough to join us here on
the rich eisen show how are you matt
rich i'm doing awesome how are you doing
how are you how are you feeling top of
the fourth quarter yesterday
oh man uh no that wasn't wasn't too good
it's it's so crazy uh you know when you
when you dig dig a hole like that you're
down 17
and you understand it just takes one
play to get it going
and there was a play in the game where
we had a little all go special
for vertical play and mitch made a throw
to anthony miller and
it just kind of propelled us and got us
going on offense which is what the
defense was
was wanting from us and and we did it
and we just kind of back and forth
started feeding off of each other
in that one quarter and before you know
we look up and there's a minute to go
and we're up by four so
those are the games you always remember
um we know we got to
get a lot better in those first three
quarters but in the end we got that w
which was uh a lot of fun in club dub
afterwards
yeah gloved up afterwards i know and and
that miller is the one who ended it as
well
with that touchdown grab with a buck 57
to go
matt neggie here on the rich eisen show
and i know when you were last
on this show um you know a couple weeks
after
nick foles was acquired you said
that the one thing that trubisky needed
to work on
which is not to get too hyped when
things are going well but to make sure
you turn the page
when something negative happens and i
thought when we hung up well
hiring somebody else to potentially push
him might
be a problem for a guy that focuses a
little bit too much and dwells a little
bit too much but yesterday
does that dispel um any notion that he
still has an issue with this
does he is that was yesterday that large
of a step forward can we take that
from week one coach well i would say
this i think it's a big step for sure
you know we
the mental toughness side it's not easy
when you know
we were moving the ball uh in in the run
game
and and we had some good play actions
and we were making strong throws
guys were getting open our struggle
yesterday rich was
was third and seven plus i mean we kept
getting in that scenario where there's
about a 20 percent chance of converting
those
uh no matter who you are and and so and
we weren't
you know so that that part was a
struggle for us and
but we fought through it and like i said
it took one play and then once we got
into that fourth quarter
our guys just started rolling and mit
you know the o-line was protecting
the wide receivers were getting open
mitch was making very accurate throws
and it felt like what it's supposed to
feel like and and then
again there was a crucial fourth and one
that we had to get that corduroy
patterson
got on on a pitch play and outran a guy
to the corner for the first and
then you know there was a good touchdown
throw uh to jimmy graham
uh another one then to anthony miller
that they uh
excuse me to uh javon wims they played
good defense on it and we just had
better offense from the throw in the in
the catch and then
the final one was a great throwing catch
by
by mitch and anthony so it just all came
together and
and i think it's a learning tool for all
of us to understand that
number one we can't do that quarters one
through three but number two
the positive is that we stuck together
and now shoot we're down 17 in the
fourth we just proved in week one we can
still come back and win
and and of course you know the the issue
is is how do you
make sure i mean how does one bottle
what happened in the fourth quarter and
on cork it from
weeks uh quarters one through three from
weeks two through
seventeen how how do you do that as a
coach what what can you
do yeah well so a few things i think
that um
for us as coaches now we finally have
film and finally have tape
of 2020 for us is what it looks like in
a live game
you know we didn't have any preseason in
practice here in training camp
everything is
is mostly thud so you're not bringing
guys live to the ground
so we can finally evaluate and critique
these guys and now we
you start building an identity of who
you are as a team
the thing i was proud of of our team in
general was
that we were able to overcome a few
penalties
uh defensively we had a few penalties
but they overcame
came and made some big stops on third
down offensively
we had one penalty in on the day and
that was a delayed game one time so
that part there is staying out of the
negative plays but
uh it gives us now a chance as coaches
to see
what we did well what we like and then
also teach these guys and then critique
ourselves too like when when did i have
a bad play call and why was that
you know when did chuck pagano have a
bad play called when was that
situational football
and you just start kind of slowly
building who you are as a team and
um when you when you're down that many
points in the fourth quarter in this
league it's hard and to come back and
win
what it does it just makes you really
strong matt neggie here on the rich
eisen show you just mentioned how
you now have film finally because there
was no preseason action and i know this
might be a loaded question
ask somebody whose team required three
quarters to finally start firing on all
cylinders
that said it there has been a large
conversation about how
crisp or you know for for no preseason
action things have looked including
officiating including obviously
play where half the league is traveling
with
protocols that they've never had to
travel with before would you
uh agree that preseason action moving
forward
has been proven to be the way to go
yeah i think so i i think what it does
is it really allows you to get that
live that live tackling um in there the
ball security for
for the you know the offensive players
the tackling for the defensive players
the full speed the energy side of it
with just getting used to the
you know going through a game i mean the
other thing that that gets lost in the
shuffle is
i mean think about too like we're
fortunate this is year three together as
a staff and there's some new coaches on
our staff but
for some of these coaches that have a
brand new staff
these guys have never gone through a
pregame ritual of like what you know
where guys go
and how you do it and where you're at
unless you do a practice run
in you know in your own facility so
there's just a lot of
first time stuff when you don't have the
preseason the preseason kind of lets you
get all the kinks out so that when you
get to week one you're rolling
and i mean just just the simplicities of
going in at halftime
and trying to you know with if there's
any new coaches hey where do you go
during halftime what's your procedure
during halftime with the short time that
you're in there so that you're effective
a lot of things that people don't think
of that that affect us as coaches and
players and i think that's where the pre
preseason can also help in other ways so
you would have an issue
if people come out of this week one and
say because predominantly a lot of
people that i talk to are saying we
don't need preseason anymore
you would have a problem with sure i and
i and i think you know there's
probably different reasons for that but
i think a lot of people
would agree that what i just said is
definitely
um there's some merit to having it um
just so that you can go through some of
some of the stuff i just talked about
not to mention too for for the players
as well so
there's probably a a balance of it
somewhere
and that's not for me to decide but but
i do think that there is some merit to
it okay so you
i guess then let's put a fine point on
it um next
um owners meeting next spring there's a
vote on this subject
you and the chicago bears would vote yes
we should have pre-season
man you put me on the spot uh i don't
know i mean
this is a conversation yeah i would
probably lean more towards that way but
but
again not having it this year i could
now say hey
we didn't have a pre-season and and so i
know that we can react
right we can react accordingly so i'm
i'm uh that's kind of down the fence but
you know that's my opinion of how it can
help in different ways matt negge here
on the rich eisen show who are we not
talking about we're all focused on
trubisky give me give me somebody that
you saw
um in in either reviewing film already
or just with your own two eyes that
we're not talking about for the bears
because we're so focused on your
quarterback
yeah no doubt i think that uh yesterday
just the one guy that jumped out when we
really needed it was anthony miller uh
you saw that in the stat line you can
see the numbers but he just brought a
lot of energy and
juice to the sideline while we were down
and you appreciate that he had a really
really good training camp
he's growing now going into his third
year
and you can see you get a guy like this
that's competitive that wants the ball
um during crucial times and we just fed
off of his energy yesterday and then
when when we gave him a chance to make a
play
he made some unbelievable plays
yesterday i mean he had a one-handed
catch on the sideline and drug both feet
in that was just
one of the better catches i've seen in a
long time and then to have that catch at
the end
you just you appreciate that he's he
gets to learn from
true pros like allen robinson allen
robinson had a catch yesterday again
that was just spectacular so
we feed off of those guys and you know
that's offensively and then
defensively um it goes without saying we
have a lot of guys on that side of the
ball they're all playing really well and
i think
um you know we're it's just getting
through the kinks
again of that week one getting
conditioned the right way tackling all
that stuff but i'm excited to see what
they do moving forward a couple more
minutes left with matt nagy chicago
bears head coach
coach of the year once removed uh from a
couple years ago right here on the rich
eisen show after a monumental comeback
win
uh for his team in detroit yesterday um
so
you're you're air jordan's the the
kicks you gave out to everyone where
where did that idea come from
when did that hatch how long have you
been planning that and i
everyone got one including ownership
right if i'm not mistaken yeah they did
they did you know uh ryan pace and
myself we were we've been discussing it
for a while it's just something you know
i'm
into you know i'm a huge basketball fan
and and i you know growing up
uh watching mj as a player
uh in his prime and just just kind of
just knowing
uh what he does as an athlete and what
he was as an athlete and just his
competitive spirit and so when we were
doing the quarantine
going all these zoom calls um it was
just an idea like hey
you know we're going to use a lot of
this stuff from the last dance
um to help our team out and and
understand what it really takes to be as
great as he was and not everybody has
that but
you can at least try to get some of it
and so there's been different times in
our team meetings that we've used
um some video of the last dance to show
who he was and what he's about obviously
being from chicago and being so close to
home and
his greatness and just for our city and
our fans there's a lot of
you can relate to it so um you know of
course you got a lot of basketball
uh a lot of our football players are
basketball fans so
what better way than to be able to uh
show our appreciation for that do
something together
and so we just we had our we had our
warm-ups and our our comfortable uh
jays and and the guys were loving it was
really cool when we
we we had the team video at night and we
had some last dance
stuff in there and then when we broke
they didn't know they were getting them
and when they all walked in to travel on
the bus
they we had them uh our equipment
manager tony amanda medlin
had them all sitting in the locker and
they loved it so it was pretty cool it
was something we'll keep going here and
it's just uh it was a fun time for us
okay i have a couple follow-up questions
uh what'd you show them did you show
them
jordan game footage or did you show
jordan's uh
trying to gain an edge on any anybody
and anything or pissed off about losing
quarters to the security guy like what
what were you trying what did you
actually show
your team to try and illustrate there's
some there's some parts in in the last
dance there's different quotes that
we've been pulling for
for months now and use them but the one
the other night was just
uh showing just a quote that he had at
the very end in the last episode
of him talking about if you're you know
if you're not a part of it if you're not
a competitor
he doesn't want you around and it shows
them you know and in practice running on
the court and sprints and he's running
you know he's always in first place and
um i think it's just a mindset we're
talking about we want to be mentally
tough
and and i'm just proud of our guys week
one down 17 in the fourth we were
mentally tough there you go
we stuck together we keep using the
words togetherness
unity and love those are the three words
they hear us talking about over and over
and over
and and week one we were mentally tough
which is what i thought was so special
about
uh you know mj is he always had to
create an edge
and even when he felt like he was he
didn't have one he he made one up
you know and he just made it work and so
i think it's very important for our guys
to understand um how
how he was wired and why he had as much
success as he did
and uh you know it's just the more of
those guys that you can get
i mean come on the sky's the limit i bet
and whose job was it to ask virginia
mccaskey what her shoe size is
let's give a shout out to that person
whose job was that yes
well we fortunately tony medlen our head
equipment manager he's been here for 30
years so
he already knows her shoe size so that
was an easy one but it was i'll tell you
what when we
when we got them and we we saw we uh
when they actually came in
and team ed showed me them it's so
there's these little tiny sneakers and
uh you know i don't i'm not sure if she
wore them or not but
obviously a big part of us and and uh
you know being able to give her some
some jays i thought it would be pretty
fun i bet
well definitely they're victory shoes
now um thank you for the call coach i
imagine where are you tonight's game uh
you'll be watching
tonight's steelers giants game because
that's that's your film session
that's who you're playing next i assume
that's what you'll be doing this evening
correct
no doubt about it yep it'll we'll have
it on we'll be watching it and
it'll be uh we'll be game planning away
as we watch it on tv but it's exciting
it's good the football's back i think
you're gonna feel it it's it's
it's a it's a big step in the right
direction for for all of us and
as always you know how much i love
coming on here and talking to you
and and and this year now i'm telling
you i didn't hold my end of the bargain
last year but this year we're getting to
play in
under your name so it's going to be in
there i'll let you know when that bad
boy is coming up you got to do that
and and you know with the lack of crowd
noise uh hopefully i will hear trubisky
say eisen eisen or something like that
that'll be
much appreciated coach i appreciate it
sure that sounds like a plan
oh and i know i've had you on but i i
can't let you go without asking your
your thoughts on andy reid's
um shield face shield that kept fogging
up
but he's the windshield wipers man he's
uh
it's that's it's too funny i was dying
laughing
when i saw that and uh it didn't shock
me but when that
when that thing was getting all fogged
up and he was trying to see what play
you wanted to call
i couldn't couldn't help from from just
hysterically laughing but
uh i'll be really curious to see what he
comes out with uh
uh next weekend but that that was
certainly a
fun thing to speak maybe he needs
advisor that could
that could help uh i think he might we
might have to send him one there you go
coach thanks for the time you take care
of yourself congrats on that take care
man you got it
it's matt naggy coach the chicago bears
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here